همم خالد الغرابلي في فقره وقفه مع الحدث
التي نخصصتها ايضا لهذا الملف الساخن خالد
مساء الخير المغرب ايضا متورط ماذا نعرف
عن هذا الاتهام الجديد لهذه الدوله
الرسميه لا احد يذكر المغرب اقول رسميا
لكن صحيفه لوماندر فرنسيه نقلت عن صحيفه
لهيبريكا الايطاليه ان احد الموقوفين في
بلجيكا واثناء التحقيق معه اقر بانه يعمل
لمنظمه تعمل لصالح قطر لكن ايضا المغرب من
الذي قال ذلك هو رفيق اذا كيلي هو ايطاليا
جنسيه وهو اعتقل معها في هذه القضيه وهو
الذي اعترف بحسب منقلته الاموند عنه
الايطاليه طيب همم كيف كان يعمل للمغرب
دائما المصدر هو الصحيفه ولا يوجد اي مصدر
رسمي يؤكد هذه المعلومات بشكل واضح وصريح
حتى نكون حقيقي حسب
عندما بدا تحقيق قبل عده اشهر الاجهزه
الامن البلجيكيه وبالتعاون مع اجهزه امن
اوروبيه وصلها معلومات ان هناك شبكه
اجنبيه من قطر ومن المغرب تقوم بمحاوله
التاثير على قرارات الاتحاد الاوروبي
والاغربي ابليكا تذهب في الكثير من
التفاصيل تذكر اسماء شخصيات مغربيه من
الاستخبارات لكن ايضا دبلوماسيين مغربيين
بانهم قاموا بالعديد من اللقاءات مع
شخصيات منهم اشخاص لم توقفهم بالفعل لكن
يبدو بحسب الصحيفه انا الموضوع كبير جدا
هناك شخصيات اخرى قد تكون متورطه في هذا
الموضوع وان كان هدف المغرب في النهايه هو
التاثير على موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي فيما
يخص الصحراء الغربيه بينما كان هدف قطر هو
تحسين صورتها بعد الانتقادات او مع
الانتقادات التي وجهت اليها بخصوص ظروف
عمل العمال همم الاجانب لبناء همم او
التحضير
لتنظيم كاس االعالم هذا ماذا ذكرته صحيفه
لابليكا وهي تتحمل طبعا مسؤوليه ما نقالته
همم رسميا اعود مره اخرى الى جانب الرسمي
وزير العدل البلجيكي سئل عن الموضوع همم
اعطى الانطباع كما لو كان هناك على الاقل
جزء من هذه المعلومات صحيحه بالقول ما
قاله هو لم يذكر المغرب مره اخرى لكن قال
ان همم
الاستخبارات البلجيكيه مع اجهزه استخبارات
اوروبيه اخرى عملت لتتاكد من معلومات او
شبهات فساد تقوم بها دول اجنبيه همم
بحسب الليمون همم يعني هذا تفسير الامومه
مره اخرى بدون ان يذكر المغرب لكن المحا
ان المغرب كان يريد
التاثير على المفاوضات التي كانت جاريه
بين المغرب والاتحاد الاوروبي بخصوص الصيد
وايضا على طريقه تسير اييي شؤون الديانه
الاسلاميه داخل البيلجيكا هذا ما قالته
الصحيفه كتفسير لها اعتبرت انه تلميح من
وزير العدل البلجيكي وحددت انه لم يذكر
المغرب همم طبعا ننتظر التحقيق ليحدد بدقه
الامور وننتظر الجانب البلجيكي رسميا
ليكشف عن الدول المتورطه لكن هناك الجزئيه
تثير الفضول الى حد ما بالعاده قرارات
الاتحاد الاوروبيه عندما تصدر هي تتعلق
بما سينفذه الاتحاد الاوروبي في مجمع
الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي وليس فقط بشان
ديانه معينه على ارض الدوله واحده وهي
بلجيكا يبدو هذه النقطه تبدو غير دقيقه
بعض الشيء لكن لكي نكون دقيقين ننتظر
لنسمع رسميا لمن توجه لاتهامات ونصر
الاتهامات بدقه مع العلم ان قطر التي وجهت
اليها اتهامات نفت ان تكون متورطه في هذا
الموضوع تبقى رئيس البرلمان الاوروبي خالد
اعلنت عن حزمه اصلاحات واسعه النطاق لعام
2023 اصلاحات لهذه الهيئه
محل محل نعرف شيئا عن هذه الاصلاحات عن
هذه الحزمه من الاصلاحات خطوط عريضه مثلا
كيفيه حمايه المبلغين عن المخالفات همم
السيد ما وصف بانه سيكون سد ثغرات لانشطه
همم موظفين سابقين في البرلمان الاوروبي
لماذا تذكر هذه النقطه لانه اكتشف ان
جماعات الضغط التي تحاول التغيير او
التاثير على قرارات البرلمان الاوروبيه
يعتمدون ويوظفون موظفين كانوا سبق وعملوا
في اروقه الاتحاد الاوروبي ليكون هم مدخل
لزملاءهم
حاليين داخل البرلمان ويسهل عمليه التواصل
معهم ما يسموا ويطلق عليهم بفاتح الابواب
ان اردت ايضا هناك حديث عن ما يسمى بسجل
الشفافيه هذا السجل الذي يفترض على جماعات
الضغط بان تكشف عن هويتها وعن اا نشاطاتها
وعن همم حجم انفاقها هناك بعض الامور التي
يتم التدقيق بشانها في هذا الموضوع سننتظر
لنعرف لكن ان نكون ايضا المثير للدهشه
وزيت هو تاخر البرلمان الاوروبي في الحديث
عن اصلاحات اليوم يعني جماعات الضغط
موجوده في بروكسل بروكسل هي ثاني مدينه في
العالم بها جماعه الضغط بعد واشنطن في
الفيديوهات المتحده همم بروكسل فيها اكثر
من اثني عشر الف جماعه ضغط اكثر من 25,000
شخص يعملون مع جماعات الضغط وهم فكره وجود
جامعات الضغط مقبوله في بروكسل
وهم ينفقون رسميا الملايين لكن هناك
تقديرات من منظمات تكافح هذه وانشطه تكافح
انشطه هذه الجامعات تقول انا تنفقوا هذه
جمعات الضغط يتعدل مليار ونصف المليار
يورو في العام طبعا البعض يقول جامعات
الضغط مهمتها بالاساس هي التواصل مع اصحاب
القرار او المؤثرين في اتخاذ القرار في
اجهزه الاتحاد الاوروبي ليشرح لها مصالح
الشركات الدول الاجنبيه احيانا حتى جماعات
منظمات غير حكوميه احيانا حتى دول من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي لها الجامعات ضغط في
البرلمان لكن هناك من يدافع عنهم يقول
مهمتهم جمعات الظهر هي شرح وجهه النظر فقط
لكن واقع الامور وعندما نسمع ما كشف من
منظمات تكافئ هذه الجامعات يقول لا الجميع
يعلم ان هناك قضايا قضايا فساد مقامنه
بشكل او باخر هناك عمليه توظيف تتم موظفين
كانوا يعمل في اجهزه الاتحاد الاوروبي
ليتم استخدامهم للتواصل مع موظفين حاليا
هناك التعديلات همم تقدم
لاعضاء برلمان الاتحاد الاوروبي تقدم ال-
ال- ال- الجزئيه المعدله بشكل خالص
ومصاع يقدم لي النائب ويطلب منه ان يتم
اعتماده ليعدل القرار واحيانا يقوم
المقابل وعد بالعمل لاحقا واحيانا يكون
المقابل مادي وهناك حتى الكاميرا الخفيه
همم لبعض الصحفيين همم ثبتت حالات قابله
فيها بعض الاشخاص الذي اعترف بانه يعمل مع
عده دول او مع عده جهات ويتقاضى من كل جهه
نحو 100,000 يورو في العام اذا جامعات
الضغط
ثقافه موجوده في بروكسل وكثيرون يعلمون
انها لا تكتفي فقط بعرض وجهات نظر ان كان
لشركات او لدول وانما تستخدم وسائل غير
قانونيه كوعود بالعمل كتقديم اموال كتقديم
هدايا والبعض يستغرب حتى من الحديث عن
وجود صدمه الان في الاتحاد الاوروبي وان
اليوم نتحدث عن الاصلاحات لماذا لم تتم
هذه الاصلاحات منذ سنوات رغم انه هذا
الامر كان معروف هذا سؤال يطرح همم حقيقه
وسننتظر تفاصيل الاصلاحات اللي نعرف ماذا
فعاليتها وماذا صدق البرنامج الاوروبي في
مواجهه هذه الظاهره المريضه شكرا لك خالد
الغرب لي كانت اذا وقفه مع الحدث شكرا لك